bonsoir du lundi au vendredi nous
faisons le tour de l'actualité locale et
en ce 13 avril il sera notamment
question de politique ancienne ministre
de nicolas sarkozy député des yvelines
valérie pécresse lance officiellement sa
campagne pour la présidence de la région
ile de france en cas de victoire elle
démissionnera de ses autres mandats
politiques également avec le résultat de
l'élection municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux un second tour
sera nécessaire les quatre listes ont la
possibilité de se maintenir
la nouvelle édition des rencontres de
l'autonomie les 14 et 16 avril à geron
dit cap sur le thème cette fois ci de
l'accompagnement et le prendre soin des
personnes âgées ou en situation de
handicap nous emparons avec nos invités
en plateau ce fait divers pour débuter
les pompiers mobilisés dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche pour un incendie de
baraques de chantier trois bâtiments
utilisés dans le cadre d'une rénovation
d'immeubles près de la gare en feu les
pompiers ont été appelés dans la nuit
vers 1h du matin pour intervenir rue
marcel rivière à la verrière pour mettre
donc fin à cet incendie sur place les
secours ont découvert trois départs de
feu se pourrait donc être se pourrait
donc être un incendie est criminel
enquête est en cours pour plus de
détails dans les prochains jours après
chantal jouanno pour lui d y en début de
semaine dernière c'était au tour ce week
end valérie pécresse pour l'ump de
lancer sa campagne pour la présidence de
la région ile-de-france depuis rosny
sous bois en seine saint denis à la
souligner que son engagement serait
totale les images sont de maxime lemaire
une arrivée en musique au milieu d'une
foule de 2000 personnes depuis la seine
saint denis valérie pécresse a voulu
marquer les esprits et adressé un
message aux électeurs
elle est la seule à pouvoir battre les
socialistes elle lors des régionales en
île de france programmée en décembre et
ce gâchis
c'est le bilan de la gauche c'est
l'échec du trio jean paul huchon marie
pierre de la gontrie son bras droit
depuis tant d'années et de la verte
emmanuelle cosse tous les franciliens le
dise on vit moins bien en ile de france
en 2015 qu'en 1998 cette ferveur me mot
courage énormément mais vous savez je
pense qu'à une envie d'alternance une
envie de changement
la région ile de france c'est le moteur
de l'avion france et si nous changeons
la région je veux j'en ferai un
laboratoire de l'alternance avec moins
d'impôts avec plus de logements plus de
transport et puis aussi plus d'emplois
un grand pacte régional en faveur de la
ruralité un soutien à l'accession
sociale ou encore un plan orsec pour les
transports figure dans ses propositions
mais bien qu'en tête dans les sondages
ces derniers mois l'inconnu front
national et la présence d'une liste udi
pourrait néanmoins hypothéquer la
victoire à l'épée créé c'est d'abord une
battante
la vie est difficile chacun de ceux qui
sont ici le savent bien
dans la vie vous battre rien n'est
acquis rien n'est donné
soutenu par nicolas sarkozy mais aussi
par françois fillon et sur le plan local
par pierre bédier président du conseil
départemental qui avaient tous fait le
déplacement valérie pécresse souhaite
donc une union dès le premier tour avec
lui dit pascal abus talent parce que
allah de la conviction parce qu'elle est
passionnée de l'île de france parce que
elle a un sens de l'intérêt général qui
est sain et dont on a besoin ici en ile
de france d'ici à l'été l'ancien
ministre actuel député entend parcourir
les 100 circonscriptions de l'île de
france
élections municipales à voisins le
bretonneux à présent c'était dimanche
les quatre listes du premier tour
peuvent se maintenir même si la maire
sortante alexandra rosetti possède une
large avance avec près de 49 % des
suffrages exprimés
les candidats ont jusqu'à demain mardi
pour déposer leurs listes en préfecture
quatre nuls à temps
avec 48 81% des suffrages la liste
d'alexandra rosetti vire très largement
en tête à l'issue du premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle de
voisins-le-bretonneux un soulagement
pour celle qui obtient 2458 voix loin
devant ses adversaires
moi je suis soulagé parce que voilà je
trouve que 48 8 avec quatre listes c'est
quand même un très beau score et
voilà je suis je suis très contente et
en route pour un deuxième tour cette
fois je m'attendais quand même à faire
un bon score
mais après
quand il ya trois listes du même bord ce
n est jamais à l'abri de mauvaises
surprises mais je pense que de ce que
j'entendais dans la population je
m'attendais quand même effectivement à
ce qu'on fasse un bon score dès le
premier tour pas de stratégie d'alliance
pour le second tour pour la maire
sortante un deuxième tour où chacun peut
se maintenir
toutes les listes ayant réalisé plus de
10% des suffrages exprimés la liste
menée par thierry gastou obtient 17,53 %
des suffrages et arrive en seconde
position ce lundi matin l'ancien
directeur de cabinet d'alexis bête a
tendu la main à olivier affonso dont la
liste est arrivée en quatrième position
pour réaliser l'union
moi j'ai toujours voulu rassembler ma
famille politique
c'était le cas au premier tour on n'y
est pas parvenu c'est à nouveau l'offre
que j'aime faire à olivier afonso nos
programmes sont finalement assez proches
je pense qu'il ya plus d'élément en tout
cas qui nous rapproche qui nous sépare
donc c'est encore mon ambition pour
qu'on puisse vraiment présenter une
nouvelle génération d'hommes et de
femmes à droite à voisins qu'ils fassent
un peu table rase du passé
on a travaillé ensemble dans le passé
beaucoup de membres son service tu es
sur la mienne se connaissent et ont
travaillé ensemble
une main tendue qu'olivia fond saut
n'avait pas encore saisi ce lundi en fin
d'après midi
il souhaitait se laisser le temps de la
réflexion dimanche soir à l'annoncé des
résultats le président du comité
syndical de champ fleuri se félicitait
de son score 16 76%
bon d'abord il ya une bonne avance
madame rose éthique est considérable qui
est vraiment considérable ce qui prouve
quand même que lévis ynwa voulait
refaire confiance à lumbres aux eti mon
sentiment sur
sur mon score à moi est extrêmement
positif dans la mesure où jean-louis
tison a fait 12 % les dernières et j'en
fais pas loin de 17 pour un candidat qui
n'était absolument pas connu ce qui
prouve bien que voisin et l'uci doit
veulent du renouvellement la liste de
rassemblement de la gauche menée par
jean âge totalise 16 91%
le conseiller municipal d'opposition élu
depuis 95 ans la commune se disait déçu
du résultat de ce premier tour je
pensais que nous pouvions faire 20 à 25%
si on est optimiste et le troisième je
pense que les chinois n'ont pas pris la
mesure de la stérilité de l'inefficacité
d'une opposition droite droite et je
craque on reproduise ce qu'on a mal vécu
pendant un an
nous appelons les chinois a voté pour
une opposition constructive efficace et
complètement désintéressé il y aura pas
d'alliance pas de côté on n'est pas pour
les alliances contre nature on n'a
aucune ambition personnelle le problème
n'est pas là on veut travailler pour
levi si noir les électeurs sont donc
rappelés aux urnes dimanche les
candidats s'inquiète d'ores et déjà de
la participation pour ce second tour qui
aura lieu le premier week-end des
vacances de pâques dimanche dernier 52 %
des vies si noah se sont déplacés aux
urnes et le risque principal dans ce
genre de situation c'est l'abstention
les électeurs vont-ils rester mobilisés
nous sommes allés à votre rencontre
aujourd'hui est révolté c'est notre
question du jour à voisin bretonne ah
bah oui ça fait sûr parce que c'est un
devoir
c'est normal non mais déjà ceux qui
votent pas mais je n'en mettrais une
amende comme ça fait récurrent récupérer
des flous ce nom déjà je suis pas très
intéressé pour voter un an après je
trouve que c'est un petit peu difficile
pour qui je voue était juste que c'est
mon devoir civique
tout simplement pour avoir un nouveau
maire un peut-être le même mais là où
l'autre quoi mais nous on voit quand
même oui on était très content très
satisfait d'être mère il ya un an donc
montrer qu'elle repasse non pas du tout
parce que
je trouve que c'est ridicule ce qui se
passe et aucune envie de voter voilà
aucune envie de faire le déplacement
pour ça j'ai vu les résultats
bon ça va être la continuité de la
sélection qui a eu lieu il ya un an et
c'est une bonne chose je trouverais ça
va faire du bien la commune lui n'est
plus maire de sa commune on en rit pas
ie n'est plus le premier édile de
coignières une page se tourne pour celui
qui dirigeait coignières depuis 1986 et
il part fâché avec la politique
l'élection de son successeur jean pierre
sauvestre s'est déroulée samedi matin
sur place florane parfait et mélanie
poquet
on n'est pas sûrs en son écharpe après
trois décennies à la tête de la
municipalité de coignières l'image est
forte
l'ancien maire passe la main à son
adjoint aux affaires économiques jean
pierre ses vestes réélu à 21 voix contre
6 par le conseil municipal
je m'attendais à cette élection ce matin
et j'en suis j'en suis très heureux je
sais que succéder à henri pailleux c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est quelque
chose de pas très aisé tout de même
parce que c'était un personnage au sein
de la commune et il l'a fait au cours de
ses trente ans de mandat des choses
extraordinaires sur la commune prendre
la suite d'henri pas mieux c'est
c'est quelque chose de demain peu
difficile tout de même 1 mais je sens
que j'ai le j'ai le courage d'assumer la
succession figure locale henri paillet
maire ump avait annoncé il ya quelques
mois sa future démission
opposé à l'entrée de coignières dans la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il a préféré quitter son poste mais
continuera à siéger au conseil municipal
n'est pas ça le plus dur est de quitter
une
canclaux qui était sale les exercent
donc depuis 86 et donc effectivement
c'est avec une grande émotion que j'ai
pris la décision donc dépasser le relais
parce que j'estime qu'à 75 ans il faut
être raisonnable
lorsqu'on part de la deuxième 200 12e
position parmi des villes les plus
vétustes département et en trente ans on
l'amène à la deuxième place à larry j g
de pois est fier du côté de l'opposition
cette décision est critiquée
c'est ce qu'affirme didier fischer
représentants de l'opposition il s'est
également présenté à l'élection de
premier magistrat
ce départ moi me faisais l'impression
d'un déni de démocratie c'est d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de premiers rien
qu'ils ont exprimé un assez clairement
dans la mesure on se présente à une
élection et que l'on dit qu'on va aller
jusqu'au bout puisque toute la campagne
a été un petit peu aussi fondée là
dessus on va aller jusqu'au bout et bien
on voit que neuf mois après l'ordre de
cesser sa déclaration des voeux il nous
annonce sa démission donc il ya quelque
part je dirais une forme de trahison
l'opposition a néanmoins salué le
travail d'henri pailleux didier fischer
s'est dit prêt à travailler en bonne
intelligence avec le nouveau maire
le prochain dossier important sera
évidemment l'entrée de la ville dont
l'intercommunalité et ce sera a priori
pour le mois de janvier cette arrivée
dans la communauté d'agglomération saint
quentin en yvelines
la loi sur l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement adopté en mars par le
sénat mais aucune date n'est encore le
connu pour la deuxième lecture par
l'assemblée nationale c'est dans ce
contexte que va se tenir
la quatrième édition des rencontres de
l'autonomie agir handicap 14 et 16 avril
invité du journal ce soir fois de
mateille qu'administrateur de gironde
icap bonsoir qui font également isabelle
arrachant sa directrice
bonsoir bienvenue à tous les deux
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le
d'introduction le flou de la mise en
place d'une loi sur le vieillissement
on pourrait aussi ajouter le bilan
mitigé dix ans après de la loi pour
l'égalité des droits et des chances sur
la question de l'accompagnement des
personnes âgées ou en situation de
handicap
il ya encore beaucoup à faire
aujourd'hui bonsoir il ya énormément de
choses à faire effectivement c'est une
loi supplémentaire alors que vous l'avez
évoqué 2000
5 2015 disons de la loi de 2005 pour
l'égalité des chances et la prise en
charge de la dépendance des personnes en
situation de vieillissement et de
handicap
c'est pas qu'il ya pas des moyens c'est
à dire si on voit le national le local
aussi nous débordons du moyen sauf qu'il
ya un problème de coordination et de
cohérence du présent chargé il ya
plusieurs écoles et chaque école se
trouve dans la politique que le schéma
départemental
selon le soir qu'on va adopter soit une
orientation directement via les
personnes handicapées ou bien les
personnes âgées mais il n'y a pas cette
cette cohérence dont la communication
entre le médico social entre le social
et entre le soir d'où la nécessité de
cette loi qui se fait attendre même si
elle a été validée déjà par le sénat la
deuxième lecture ya pas encore de date
pour à l'assemblée nationale exactement
et la ciste beaucoup sur cette cohérence
effectivement d'intervention aujourd'hui
une personne âgée par exemple qui décide
de se maintenir à domicile a acquis ne
faut pas aller dans un établissement de
type ehpad se trouve face à plusieurs
intervenants donc des auxiliaires de vie
pour tous qui est héros pas tout ce qui
est ménage tout ce qui est aide à
domicile des soins infirmiers
des séances de kiné ponctuellement des
d
des courses à l'extérieur mais tous ces
gens là ne se coordonnent pas c'est
aveyron ils ne se connaissent pas entre
elles et il n'y a pas un prescripteur
si vous voulez identifié en tant que tel
pour coordonner l'ensemble de ses
prestations
donc ça c'est pour le contexte et dans
ce cadre-là 14 16 avril ce colloque que
vous organisez pour gérer handicap avec
des ateliers aussi ça sera pour le 16 le
colloque c'est le sait le 14 et le thème
c'est prendre soin une course aux
obstacles pouvez nous en dire plus
peut-être nous présenter le thème du
colloque
ben comme vient de le dire monsieur
madec tous les intervenants
professionnels déjà ne se connaissent
pas la famille l'entourage au sens large
prend soin aussi des personnes
vulnérables personnes en situation de
handicap personnes âgées comment faire
pour que se prendre soin deviennent
beaucoup plus simple beaucoup plus
fluide pour tout le monde aussi bien
pour les personnes qui le vivent au
quotidien qui sont directement touchés
par parce la dépendance ou la situation
de vulnérabilité que pour les
professionnels et les proches qui les
accompagnent donc le colloque va
permettre d'échanger autour de toutes
thématiques là est dégagée peut-être des
solutions des pistes guider grand public
est ce que le grand public est convié
aussi sûr que c'est là la grande
thématique de ce colloque et on veut
être haussés aussi originaux
habituellement on l'a fait jusqu'à
présent sur la quatrième édition nous
avons fait effectivement des actes qui
ont été publiés là nous faisons le pari
de faire quasiment des recommandations à
travers ces actes là puisqu'on peut on
fait intervenir des sociologues aucun
formulaire des juristes de renommée
internationale des humoristes aussi hein
parce que c'est un set ou thématiques
qu'on peut aborder sous cet angle là et
notre notre idée c'est de pouvoir
pourquoi pas présenter effectivement une
plate forme de revendications pour le
prochain schéma départemental pour la
prise en charge et l'accompagnement des
personnes dépendantes et des personnes
handicapées vieillissantes
donc ça doit permettre un changement y
aura une finalité au colloque qui sera
organisé d'infléchir les politiques en
tout cas de coordonner mieux c'est ce
que nous espérons et nous poussons
peut-être prendre un bâton du pèlerin
avec d'autres acteurs pour pouvoir
sensibiliser les élus locaux lés
que ce soit les maires que ce soit les
conseillers départementaux pour qu'on
puisse effectivement asseoir une
politique digne de ce nom là puisque la
forme la france a la chance je veux dire
grâce à la médecine
voir l'avancée en âge et puis nous avons
aussi l'ambition de pouvoir aussi former
et accompagner les accompagnateurs pour
qu'ils puissent accomplir leur tâche de
la façon la plus belle et la plus
cohérente tout à l'heure il ya des
moyens
il ya une prise de conscience aussi lé
real il existe des deux des pouvoirs
publics
les personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans
aujourd'hui c'est 15 millions de
personnes 24 millions normalement en
2060 pour la france il ya une prise de
conscience de cette problématique il ya
une prise de conscience mais le problème
qu'on constate si on fait un zoom sur
par exemple le département des yvelines
il y à la politique départementale mais
il ya aussi les politiques communales
est ce que nous regrettons c'est que
chaque commune reste sur son pré carré
en quelque sorte c'est à dire mais
personnes âgées c'est un mois ça
m'appartient je le partage avec personne
et ça je trouve ça regrettable ce qu'il
faut aussi selon lui il ya plusieurs
volets peut-être à prendre en contre
c'est l'anticipation l'accompagnement
l'adaptation globale de la société
tout ça c'est des volets que la loi
prévoit même s'il faut encore attendre
cette seconde lecture toujours par
l'assemblée nationale il ya plusieurs
volets à prendre l'anticipation c'est
important va l'anticipation la loi et
l'introduit effectivement la prise de
conscience et la prise en charge dès
l'âge de la retraite
1 donc il ya un système de diagnostic
qui doit être permanent pour effectuer
le monde mettre en place un système de
prévention qui permet un moment donné de
travailler sur des plateaux techniques
ou des démarches et de processus
d'accompagnement de ces personnes là
nous avons aussi un certain nombre de
de palette de propositions que ce soit
dans les lots maintien à domicile que ce
soit le les maisons de retraite que ce
soit les deux éventuellement il faut
prévoir aussi pour notamment des
personnes qui sont atteintes de démence
d'alzheimer des moyens du répit pour les
aidants familiaux et dieu sait on l'a
beaucoup et pas mal de d'enfants qui se
sacrifient dans ce sens là et qui n'ont
aucun soutien aucune aide
pour l accompagnement de leurs parents
4e édition des rencontres de l'autonomie
2015 14 et 16 avril sur saint quentin en
yvelines pour le colloque ce sera au
théâtre national sur
montigny-le-bretonneux pour les ateliers
en revanche ce sera dans vos locaux à
magny les hameaux de gironde icap les
ateliers vont se dérouler comme en tout
au long de la journée
sachant qu'il ya un site internet il va
s'afficher si les gens veulent plus
d'informations sur tous des ateliers
s'adressent aussi à tous les publics
professionnels comme comme le grand
public des ateliers d'information mais
aussi des ateliers de mise en pratique
comment quand on est aidé en se détendre
par l'activité physique on parlait de
prévention comment prévenir un petit peu
la perte d'autonomie par par l'activité
physique comment des ateliers de
relaxation et puis des ateliers
d'information sur ce qui existe déjà sur
le territoire puisque effectivement on a
un territoire très riche et que fait une
équipe spécialisée alzheimer que fait
une équipe qui accompagne post accident
vasculaire cérébral que font tous les
professionnels quel est le rôle
quels sont les rôles et les missions des
uns et des autres quel est le rôle de
gérant des caps justement alors c'est
l'occasion d'en reparler pour ceux qui
connaissent pas encore vraiment la
structure
quelle est la mission le rôle de gérant
dikaba c'est de regrouper tous ses
acteurs de l'accompagnement est
d'essayer d'apporter cette cohérence au
niveau au niveau du territoire une
politique solidaire pour les personnes
en perte en perte d'autonomie personnes
en situation de handicap personnes âgées
gérant des caps qui fonctionne bien
aujourd'hui
oui la situation de faire
nous avons les agonistes et alzheimer
qui est
qui fait partie donc l'hôpital plaisir
nous accueillons aussi en a que senior
nous avons un service d'accompagnement
aux des personnes en situation de
handicap vieillissante dans les
personnes qui sortent d'ailleurs du
milieu de travail notamment des esat
nous avons aussi des plateaux de
formation des appartements aménagés pour
les futurs auxiliaire de vie ou les
aides à domicile
nous travaillons aussi avec des
organismes de formation pour tout ce qui
est formation continue long pour se
montre compétences
c'est une expérience originale
je veux pas me retirer pour dire sur la
france entière mais c'est un groupement
qui s'est spécialisé dans la
gérontologie effectivement que ce soit
personnes âgées dépendantes aux
personnes en situation de handicap et
glissante et une nouvelle fois on vous
renvoie au site internet pour en savoir
plus sur la 4ème édition des rencontres
de l'autonomie 14 et 16 avril et puis
sur travail globale menée par gérondi
cap sur ce territoire de 50 ans merci à
tous les deux d'être venu aujourd'hui en
plateau la suite du journal c'est avec
les communautés chrétienne et musulmane
de coignières qui ont organisé une
collecte de denrées alimentaires ce week
end au profit est du centre des restos
du coeur de la verrière une deuxième
édition qui a connu un véritable succès
comme nous l'expliqué yolaine thorez et
un maximum n il fallait des bras costaud
pour récupérer toutes ces denrées
alimentaires le centre des restos du
coeur de la verrière stocks les produits
collectés ce week end par deux
associations de coignières l'une
chrétienne l'autre musulman c'est
important sur une petite commune de voir
que qu'on peut travailler à deux
religions différentes sur une action
commune
de solidarité puisque nous avons des
valeurs communes donc c'était important
de faire quelque chose ensemble
et faire voir au public de témoigner qu
on peut sans temps de faire quelque
chose de commun c'est la deuxième année
que les communautés se réunissent pour
cette action les coignard rien déposer
les produits à la sortie de leurs
courses et elles ont été plus généreux
cette année en une journée plus d'une
tonne de denrées a été collecté contre
500 kilos l'année dernière une action
utile et solidaire donc est aussi
humaine ça sert les deux communautés à
mieux se connaître à mieux vivre
ensemble et incarner cette valeur de
fraternité républicaine qui est la leur
aussi
cher et religieuses au niveau de notre
notre foi prochain rendez vous le
vendredi 22 mai une rencontre inter
religieuse sur le thème des valeurs est
ouverte à tous du sport pour terminer ce
journal une course de caisses à savon
était organisé ce week end à villiers
saint frédéric une vingtaine de bolides
sans moteur qui ont dévalé les pentes de
la commune michael et demi d'euros
mélanie poker et florennes parfait
mathis 7 ans et conducteur d'un bolide
rouge
j'avais un peu peur au départ mais après
le tome juge y habituer pour la
troisième année consécutive une
vingtaine de caisses à savon des vallées
ce dimanche les 800 mètres de la rue de
la vallée à villiers saint frédéric
sensations fortes garanties ici c'est
une toute petite descente et c'est vrai
que on n'a pas la sensation réelle de
vitesse mais sur d'autres compétitions
en france on peut aller allègrement à 80
90 km heure est donc vraiment avoir de
très bonnes sensations sachant qu'on est
à trois centimètres du sol dans la
journée est différent différents types
de descente parfois fallu aller le plus
loin possible parfois c'était la
précision il fallait s'arrêter un
endroit bien précis juste après la ligne
d'arrivée donc là ya pas de
chronométrage ce n'est pas une
compétition
c'est vraiment une manifestation qui est
destiné à 1
entre au grand public la caisse sommes
au delà de l'aspect compétition c'est
surtout le look des voitures qui attire
l'oeil les enfants aidés par leurs
parents ont passé des dizaines d'heures
à travailler l'aérodynamisme et la
carrosserie de leur véhicule
il faut bien monté parce que la
direction aussi un problème est en
pleine course haut la direction n'est
franck qu'il faut bien monté est ce
qu'il ya un truc qui se cassent et voilà
c'est ce serait dommage de faire un
accident
on va voir différents échelons on va
voir des caisses au curé qui vont être
vraiment préparés que des roues de vélo
donc ça ça va pas coûter très très cher
ça va être des éléments de récupération
et après ceux qui veulent vraiment
pratiquer cette activité en tant que
sport
par contre on va voir des véhicules qui
vont pouvoir aller monter jusqu'à 4000
euros si vous avez manqué la course de
villiers saint frédéric un autre grand
prix programmé à fontenay le fleury le
dimanche 10 mai tout cela est très
sérieux 800 pilotes pratiquer cette
discipline en france prochain journal
demain mardi à la présentation à
catherine mulato je vous retrouverai
juste après pour un 7 8 politique
consacrée à voisins le bretonneux et je
recevrai en plateau pour un débat les
candidats du second tour de cette
élection municipale partielle sur la
commune tout de suite sur télé fils de
7,8 sport c'est avec michael almy deux
roues très bonne soirée